paroles à arrangé carucci pour le groupe
UMP
c'est le président monsieur le ministre
hier le Sénat a rejeté le budget ce
matin il a confirmé son rejet du texte
sur la sécurité sociale pour nous trop
d'impôts trop de taxes pas assez de
baisse de la dépense publique pour nous
trop de promesses trop d'engagement
entre leur ras-le-bol fiscal entre le
ras-le-bol fiscal dénoncé par Monsieur
Moscovici la pose fiscale dénoncée ou
souhaité par le Président de la
République alors que les français
reçoivent leurs feuilles d'impôts et ne
voient ni pose fiscale ni réduction de
l'impôt quant à l'engagement du Premier
ministre sur la réforme fiscale c'est
évidemment un leur qui consiste à dire
demain orace gratis mais en réalité tant
qu'il n'y a pas eu de baisse massive des
dépenses publiques il ne peut pas y
avoir de baisse de l'impôt mais enfin on
va pendant quelques temps si j'ai bien
compris le président de la République
d'ailleurs pendant tout le monde a donc
ça peut durer et sans baisse d'impôts
faire des réformes promettre beaucoup ne
tenir pas grand chose
choc du verbe promesse également en
matière de chômage il y a quelques mois
le président de la République nous a
annoncé l'inversion de la courbe du
chômage et puis voilà
on continue de détruire de l'emploi
notamment de l'emploi industriel de
manière massive des plans sociaux se
multiplient les deux localisation
continue les investisseurs nationaux
étrangers n'y croient pas et
n'investissent pas résultat des courses
résultat des courses le président de la
République lui-même ce matin c'est le
moins que l'on puisse dire ne semble
plus tout à fait d'accord avec lui-même
c'est à dire que il dit qu'il y aura
certes une inversion un jour
le problème étant de savoir quel jour
mais bon un jour en vrai c'est toujours
pareil c'est le choc du verbe et la
réalité et la réalité elle est là elle
est concrète elle est immédiate alors
Monsieur le Ministre visiblement la
boîte à outils a disparu où elle est
enterrée dans le jardin
visiblement on a plus de solutions
miracle visiblement la France continue
d'avoir une situation pire que ses
voisins qui eux continuent de se
redresser nous nous sommes en berne en
berne pour l'investissement en berne
pour l'emploi en berne pour la fiscalité
quand nos voisins se redressent je
n'aurais pas la cruauté monsieur le
ministre comme certains députés
socialistes l'ont fait hier encore de
demander quand est-ce qu'on change de
gouvernement mais je vous demande
seulement parce que pour nous c'est pas
une question d'homme c'est une question
de cap de décision et de lignes
politiques moi je vous demande seulement
monsieur le ministre quand est-ce que ce
gouvernement va décider de changer de
cap pour redonner confiance aux Français
pour écouter l'exaspération
et pour prendre conscience que la France
ne peut pas continuer comme ça merci
Monsieur Bernard Cazeneuve
bien monsieur le sénateur caoutchi merci
beaucoup pour cette question qui est
très emblématique de ce que la nuance
peut produire de meilleur
c'était extrêmement équilibré absolument
pas partisan et très emblématique de la
plus pure bonne foi bon vous évoquez
trois sujets le premier sujet est celui
de la fiscalité le deuxième sujet est
celui de la dépense et le troisième
sujet celui de l'emploi je vais donc
répondre aux trois questions que vous
posez pour ce qui concerne la dépense
vous considérez aujourd'hui qu'elle est
insuffisamment maîtrisée je veux
simplement vous rappeler des chiffres
car ils sont finalement le seul
instrument qui est de nature nous
remettre d'accord l'un avec l'autre
pendant les 5 années du gouvernement
auquel vous avez participé la dépense
publique a augmenté de 170 millions
d'euros
si je donne des chiffres de pourcentage
de la dépense publique la dépense
publique a augmenté en moyenne entre
2002 et 2012 c'est-à-dire pendant les 10
ans d'exercices du pouvoir par les
gouvernements que vous soutiez en
moyenne de plus de 2%. le budget que
vous avez rejeté hier est un budget qui
diminue de 1,5 milliards les dépenses de
l'État au terme de 15 milliards
d'économies c'est pas assez dites-vous
monsieur karucci c'est intéressant
entendre 15 milliards en un an c'est pas
assez mais lorsque Monsieur carucci
soutenait un gouvernement qui proposait
10 milliards en trois ans c'était
beaucoup j'ai du mal à comprendre ce
raisonnement qui consiste à considérer
que 15 milliards en un an c'est pas
assez mais 10 milliards en trois ans
c'est beaucoup deuxièmement vous parlez
des impôts monsieur carochi c'est la
deuxième élément de réponse que je
voudrais vous donner les impôts ils ont
augmenté de 20 milliards
en 2011 ils ont augmenté de 20 milliards
en 2012 ils ont augmenté de 20 milliards
en 2013 et quand vous les avez augmentés
monsieur caoutchi les impôts pas vous
mais enfin le gouvernement auquel vous
apparteniez vous vous avez sans doute
subi à ce moment-là vous avez pris un
certain nombre de mesures concernant la
réindexation du barème de l'impôt sur le
revenu la suppression des demi-part des
veuves qui ont considérablement accrus
les inégalités et bien nous nous
réindexons le barème de l'impôt sur le
revenu nous augmentons le revenu fiscal
de référence nous mettons en place une
des cotes et nous créons les conditions
cette année d'une augmentation de la
pression fiscale de 1 milliard d'euros
si on neutralise l'effet de l'allure
contre la fraude c'est-à-dire 20 fois
moins que le dernier budget fait par
Madame Pécresse voilà la réalité de ce
qu'est la fiscalité ensuite vous parlez
de l'emploi je terminerai par là le
nombre d'emplois industriels détruits
pendant la période où vous avez exercé
la responsabilité pendant les cinq
dernières années
750 000 emplois industriels détruits et
bien je veux vous confirmer ici que
l'objectif d'inversion de la courbe du
chômage à la fin de l'année et bien
maintenu et que nous ferons de la lutte
contre le chômage et pour l'emploi et la
croissance et le redressement de notre
appareil productif la priorité du
quinquennat merci